[Music]
well there was love in Brooklyn this
weekend Beyonce and her man jay-z hosted
a major concert and queen bee show just
how much of a boss she really is after
suffering a pretty nasty cut on stage
Kevin Frazier was the only TV reporter
waiting for her when she stepped off
stick to preach salvation you know I
love you too
Beyonce proving yet again why she's the
Queen after her earring got caught in
her epic brain halfway through her set
watch as she wipes the blood from her
ear and keeps singing she didn't even
flinch the incident sent the Beehive
into a frenzy several fans took to
social media cutting their own ears with
the hashtag bleed for Beyonce Nicki
Minaj rocked the crowd in her second
outfit up the night a sheer bodysuit so
sheer we can't even show you all of it
give oh honey so tall that my body's got
a carpet Nicki how was it but epic
doesn't even begin to cover the vibe
backstage Kevin was in the middle of all
the madness
check out Alicia Keys on her way to the
stage doing a little damage control
after being photographed
kind of like won't you give me a sign
Oh
[Music]
unless they're not hungry like smash TI
common Lauryn Hill and dnce were all on
the bill at the sold-out title concert
benefiting the Robin Hood Foundation
aimed at ending poverty in New York City
how was it out there first of all man it
was amazing man it's always amazing to
come here man former front of Brooklyn
at the bar clean I live right down the
street from here so it's like I'm like
y'all performing like a half a block
from my place so let's go did you walk
her dry I walk I walked I walked in my
whole team and my and my family also
backstage
Julian Roland Howard University student
Nick Cannon you know we had to ask
how's college life going it's amazing uh
I got I got two papers due on Monday so
I better hurry up anything else I should
be talking about
I don't think okay good go get down go
go to the bathroom
[Music]
you